what's up buddy
hi rich how are you i'm doing good
so yeah i started my own electrical
business not too long ago
yeah that's right i'm a master
electrician exactly
and i'm way over my head with work
already
should i crank up
yeah that's a good problem
should i crank up my rate
uh in the field usually 10 to 12 and
then
that's not counting off a week or seven
days a week or
six to seven yeah
what's your rate right now
uh 90 an hour and what's the going rate
for most people in your industry
um
anywhere from 80 to 100 some odd dollars
an hour okay and do you specialize in
anything that you could charge more for
uh nothing too specialized and
basically damn good at everything but uh
so
i'm gonna provide two um two points to
this question first is yes definitely
increase your rates
100 110 dollars an hour you know
whatever is it you need to move it up to
but your rates are too low because
you're super busy right so if somebody
somebody's like hey you know i need you
on thursday okay my rate's 110
well you know your rate last year was
90. yeah well i'm fully booked you know
do you want the slot or not right i mean
you clearly don't have a problem booking
people so there's that the other thing
is i'm going to share a story that i got
from a locksmith once so another trades
guy
and you know if you've been in
locksmithing
for a period of time you don't need to
try different keys to fix a lock or
you're not going through all the trial
and error of like this brand from it's
manufactured in germany and this key
over here sort of thing over here you're
not going through all that that might
take you you know the entire billable
hour
so
this guy got good at his job and rather
than taking an hour to get something
done to earn the money he would he would
sometimes get it done in like 15 minutes
10 minutes and then people would get
pissed
because
because it would get it done so quickly
but he would build him for the hour
right because it was a minimum hour
so
he started horsing around like he
started you know like having a fiddle
you know like pretend like basically
acting to like eat up time
and then he thought to himself why the
hell am i doing this he goes if it takes
me 10 minutes it takes me 10 minutes i
built you know for the hour i'm only
taking 10 minutes because i learned how
to do it over the 20 years so i didn't
have to waste an hour of my time or my
customers time
right so when he flipped the script into
thinking in his head
you know he just got things done a lot
quicker and they understood why his
billable rate was that right i mean he
doesn't have to go through 37 different
trials it's like he knows it's a
german lock built between this time and
it needs this piece goes right for it
gets it done in five ten minutes and he
fixes it so there's just a little story
that i want to share because he's also
another trades guy so
the thing with your business with what
you're doing is you're always exchanging
time for money right because your rate's
90 dollars an hour and there's only so
many hours in the day and you have to
sleep and you have to you know do other
things you know throughout the day as
well right you need some rest time too
so
you have to be super careful with
burning yourself it's basically you know
taking the candle and burning it on both
ends
oh yeah you know then you burn out guys
like you
guys like you when you get older you
know you get sick you've got a immune
issue because you're stressed out your
entire life because you're so work you
used to working like 11 12 hours a day
six days a week like your body burns off
a lot quicker than the average guy that
knows how to like take time and unplug
and maybe not you know does things to
recharge himself so you got to be
careful with that so charge an
appropriate rate for what you do right
if you're if you're able to solve
problems and you can do it in 15 minutes
but you would normally like like the new
guy would bill you know for one hour
charge a premium rate like why not
right you can charge even higher rates
if you specialize in in in certain like
niches that most people don't have the
skills to solve problems in right i mean
if there's a hundred electricians and
then there's two of you that can solve a
specific problem then your rate should
be much higher
yeah it's uh it's a tough one in my
field because i'm damn good at what i do
but also run the business
so i pull myself out of the field
if i hire guys they won't be near as
efficient right and you're still trying
to sell that service yeah and you know
then they you got to build them out at
you know a certain rate and then you've
got to pay them an hourly rate so
they're so you're basically doing
arbitrage or you're making money off
their time but they're never going to do
the job as good as their efficiency
that's one of the things you got to
understand about employees another thing
i don't like about employees is that
they're never going to do it up to your
standard like you have to accept an
employee
or somebody that works for you like even
a manager like as good as they might be
they might only be able to complete the
task at eighty percent of the um
rate that you could right like they'll
never get it spot on as quickly as you
can get it that may take longer they
might not do the best job i remember i
had this welder friend not um chris but
another guy
and he was like looking at the welds of
one of his guys and they were just
they were just like like like he
was embarrassed to have his company name
on welts right so it's like you
know he either had to make a decision
like this guy either has to learn how to
weld properly or he's got to get rid of
him
yeah yeah for sure yeah you run into
that all the time yeah so you're running
stuff like that anyway does that help
yeah thanks appreciate your time
you